James Harden just sold 10 000 bottles of
wine in five seconds Hardin was on a
live stream that had over 15 million
viewers with famous Chinese tick tocker
named crazy brother Yang The Tick tocker
told Hardin that he could blow up his
wine business in an instant and once he
shouted ready go to the chat within
seconds 5 000 bottles were sold a second
round of bottles sold out quickly again
and it left hard and speechless he was
so shocked that he had to bust out a
cartwheel on the stream before this he
had only sold a few cases a day but
after that happened pardon now feels
like Chinese fans deserve to come see
him play now we know why Harden will
always have a love for China